je me suis dit c'est dingue quoi comme
ça peut nous nous bouleverser nous nous
remuer quoi donc pareil j'ai fait un
lien et puis que ce soit la musique
tzigane de mes grands-parents et puis
les larmes qui venaient je me suis dit
la musique
c'est puissance c'est quelque chose
Michel jonaszman soit bonsoir bien alors
bienvenue à Tout le monde en parle
d'abord et puis vous avez déclaré pour
beaucoup de monde quand on vous voit pas
à la télé c'est que vous faites rien et
c'est chiant de se taper 18 heures de
studio c'est un peu emmerdant quoi oui
ça ça m'est arrivé souvent sortait du
studio il était 7h du mat il y avait des
gens qui qui me croisaient dans la rue
qui me disent bah alors qu'est-ce que
vous foutez on vous voit plus etc c'est
vrai que les gens quand ils voient pas
la télévision ils pensent que vous
travaillez pas moi j'ai besoin j'ai
besoin de temps pour écrire j'ai besoin
de temps pour enregistrer c'est normal
alors Daniel Gilbert
à mon avis quatre
alors vous venez pas vous venez pas pour
rien parce que vous venez pour un pour
un film et puis pour un 10 on va parler
des on va parler des deux vous savez
comment ça se passe non
c'est Lolo est-ce que vous êtes dans une
soirée
positive ce soir
je vais en faire autant
film qui s'appelle princesse mahouchka
qui est un film qui jamais sorti il
retrouve une photo c'est une très belle
histoire et retrouve une photo de de
Sylvain Marceau avec une actrice qui
s'appelle Lisa Morin qui jouait par
Marion Cotillard quand elle est jeune et
par jeune Moreau quelques années plus
tard et donc il retrouve cette Lisa Mora
et elle lui raconte la passion qu'ils
ont connu tous les deux c'est à dire
elle est Sylvain Marceau l'acteur en
1939 ils sont rentrés dans sanatorium
dans les Alpes et puis la guerre est
arrivée et voilà et puis ils ont été
évidemment séparés je suis assez fier
d'avoir participé à ce film parce que
c'est un film après l'avoir vu que l'on
garde en soit longtemps vous savez on
voit des images on se souvient de d'une
émotion ressentie je crois que c'est ça
bon film c'est un film qui s'arrête pas
quand la quand la salle sera lui quand
on le garde alors ce Sylvain Marceau en
fait dans le film il s'appelle Sylvain
Caplan en fait mais il a sa mère l'a
élevé n'a pas fait circoncire elle a
élevé chrétiennement en lui parlant de
nouveaux rameaux en disant tu es un
nouveau rameau le rameau nouveau le
Ramon nouveau et il prend conscience en
fait pendant le film toute l'histoire il
prend conscience de sa judéité il
choisit d'avoir le sort des autres juifs
dans le film et il est déporté par les
nazis et Sam votre fils lui aussi c'est
ça qui est intéressant dans le film
c'est à dire que lui aussi vous et sa
mère lui avait jamais vraiment parlé de
ça c'est toujours le Ramon nouveau et il
prend conscience de sa judéité il prend
conscience aussi de qui est son père de
toute façon je crois que c'est une
question qu'on se trimbale tous quoi
qu'on se pose au moins une fois dans sa
vie quand on est juif ce truc de
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'être juif la
question elle est plus brûlante à
l'époque de l'occupation pour pour
Sylvain évidemment elle est vécue d'une
façon plus brudante plus dramatique je
dirais mais elle est elle est la même
aujourd'hui pour pour ça mon fils à un
moment nous on était deux enfants cachés
pendant la guerre il y a quand Pierre
Rambla vous a contacté vous êtes allé le
voir vous avez lu cette scène et vous
avez eu beaucoup d'émotion ce qui est
normal vous avez et construire levé la
tête vous avez vu grambla avait les
larmes aux yeux aussi et donc évidemment
l'affaire était oui elle était l'affaire
était là vous avez compris tous les deux
en même temps que vous ensemble et c'est
aussi le cinéma qui fait le lien entre
ces deux ces deux destins ces deux
hommes mais surtout pour moi Lisa c'est
vraiment un film d'amour quoi le vrai
lien entre toutes ces destinées dont
vous avez très bien parlé c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment l'amour mais alors vous
contrairement à au héros du film enfin
au 2 héros qui sont Sylvain et Sam vous
êtes toujours su vous origines on n'a
pas essayé de vous élever dans votre
famille
chrétiennement etc que je vous ai
toujours su vous êtes toujours eu ce
sentiment d'appartenir vous dites j'ai
le sentiment d'appartenir à un peuple
vous saviez toujours mais vous dites
aussi ce sentiment peut être dangereux
pourquoi c'est vrai que je me suis
toujours senti juif bien sûr je l'ai
toujours su mais j'ai pas été élevé dans
une tradition religieuse enfin
religieuse shabbat etc il y avait pas
c'est mais donc moi mon le premier
contact que j'ai eu avec
c'est la douleur ce qu'on me racontait
ce qu'on me disait moi c'était c'est
douloureux d'être juif c'était les
histoires de déportation de ma famille
etc donc
si j'ai dit que c'était dangereux c'est
parce que oui c'est ce qui c'est ce
qu'on me faisait 47 vous voyez c'est pas
très loin
nos amis qui ne savent pas c'était le
centre de tri pour expédier les femmes
dans toutes les dans toute l'Allemagne
c'est fou d'être né à Drancy
bien que cette génération là qui est
venue tout de suite un peu après la
guerre pourquoi il y en a beaucoup
qui n'était pas circoncis il y avait
encore c'était une des raisons on sait
jamais on a peur que vous pensez dans le
film on l'a vu Benjamin que je joue le
père on ne sait jamais ça peut
recommencer il y avait tellement c'était
tellement fort et tellement intense quoi
cette peur là que voilà on sait jamais
alors vous vous êtes une famille
d'origine juive hongroise donc comme je
l'ai dit né à Drancy votre père était
représentant de commerce qui est pas
loin en fait du personnage que vous
jouez dans le film et le je lui ai
écouté de la musique tzigane chez les
grands-parents on allait chez les
grands-parents et puis il sortait le
tourne-disque là tu es pas là puis il
sortait les vieux disques de tzigane
hongrois et c'est vrai que ça a été mon
mon premier contact avec la musique pour
moi la musique c'était ça la musique ça
a transformé les gens savaient un
pouvoir incroyable quoi ça au bout d'un
moment avec le vin et puis la musique en
plus c'était quand même des gens qui
avaient qui étaient des rescapés de la
joie donc ils avaient ils disaient il
faut vivre la vie comme un miracle quoi
parce que c'est vrai qu'il aurait pu
leur arriver le fait d'être toujours là
d'être toujours en vie c'est leur donner
une force extraordinaire
donc en même temps une douleur de ce
qu'ils ont vécu ou de ce que leurs amis
ou leurs familles ou leurs parents ont
vécu et en même temps une telle joie de
vivre qu'on passe du rire aux larmes il
y a pas de banalité on rit on pleure
mais en tout cas on est il y a une joie
l'homme il est pas là pour souffrir quoi
il est il y a une joie intérieure comme
si comme si c'était en attente quoi
comme si elle attendait pour pour voir
s'ex
[Musique]
pour essayer parce que les gens sont
d'accord on est tous perdus dans notre
époque dites-leur voilà pourquoi vous
vous pensez quelque chose à trouver de
ce côté là
d'accord qu'est-ce que c'est qu'une
religion qu'est-ce que c'est que les
religions à quoi ça sert
pour moi ce sont des moyens qui
permettent aux hommes des moyens qui
diffèrent selon les hommes selon les
lieux selon les périodes qui permettent
aux hommes de se mettre en relation avec
leur
nature divine ça c'est une question de
foi mais il y a pas de vérité là-dedans
et à partir du moment où l'appel ou le
est suffisamment intense ou le besoin
est suffisamment intense pour se mettre
en relation avec cette nature divine
intérieure
tous les moyens sont bons c'est pas les
moyens qui comptent on s'en fout là-bas
ce qui compte vraiment c'est est-ce
qu'il est vraiment intense ton besoin
cet appel là vers quoi vers quelque
chose que tu sens toi qui est riche qui
est beau qui alors il y a des réponses
quelquefois avec cette question qu'on se
trimbale mais depuis qu'on est môme moi
je me trimbale une question depuis que
je suis moi mais il y a quelque chose
qu'on m'explique pas et quelque chose
d'autre et il y a des réponses qui qui
résonnent plus que d'autres alors c'est
vrai quand j'ai rencontré je serais
robbindo et mère et ça te prennent ça a
été une réponse forte parce que il me
parlait pas des choses en isme et de
religion et Machin il me disait il y a
une prochaine étape dans notre évolution
et ça c'est une vraie révolution et ça
ça m'a pris ça pour nos amis c'est que
l'état actuel de n'est qu'un des
maillons n'est qu'un des équipes
il y a quelque chose
si nous ne sommes pas le sommet de
l'évolution
mais là nous sommes des explorateurs de
quoi construit
quand même et moi c'est plus que toi
alors la preuve bien non mais voilà
c'était exploration m'intéresse et donc
puisque tu m'as c'est vrai que la
télévision
à dire des choses intéressantes
et d'autres bien sûr mais d'être surtout
pur et intense dans son appel et dans
son besoin voilà on n'est pas obligé de
dire que des conneries la télé bien
alors un jour alors je reprends votre
votre enfance parce que c'est quand même
assez extraordinaire un jour vous
découvrez complètement par hasard ça
vous amène là où vous êtes arrivé après
que votre père était chanteur en fait il
était en gris chanteur de cabaret et que
ses parents étaient chanteurs d'opérette
non euh non
vous avez un autre grand-père maternel
celui-là qui était chanteur à la
synagogue que je n'ai pas connu voilà
donc en fait vous venez vous êtes un
jour vous avez découvert que vous veniez
d'une famille de chanteurs simplement
votre père il est pas eu de ça n'avait
pas oui c'est votre père qui un jour
vous amené dans les années 60 au début
des années 60 à l'Olympia et vous avez
vu Edith Piaf c'était un vous avez
décidé de devenir artiste à ce moment-là
non mais c'était un vrai choc quoi
c'était incroyable cette petite bonne
femme je me souviens de ce de ce
moment-là quoi ça a été le la première
fois que j'étais dans un music-haut
c'était à l'Olympia on avait annoncé le
nom d'Édith Piaf le rideau était fermé
vous savez à cette époque là le chanteur
et on voyait pas les musiciens ils
rentraient comme ça puis elle est
rentrée tout doucement elle était déjà
un petit peu c'était tout doucement sous
les applaudissements elle s'est plantée
devant le micro cette petite bonne femme
avec sa petite robe noire avec ses mains
comme ça elle a plaqué ses mains sur
contre ses cuisses et elle a chanté et
puis sa voix qui remplissait cet espace
de l'Olympia et puis nous on était là
puis je me suis dit waouh c'est quoi ce
truc là cette chanson vous savez une
force avait une puissance la chanson je
me suis dit c'est dingue quoi comme ça
peut nous nous bouleverser nous nous
remuer quoi donc pareil j'ai fait un
lien et puis que ce soit la musique
tzigane de mes grands-parents et puis
les larmes qui venaient je me suis dit
la musique
c'est quelque chose et voilà et alors le
vrai déclic c'est en 62 en fait vous
avez 15 ans et vous claquez la porte du
lycée vous cassez vous êtes bon faut
dire la vérité j'étais pas doué j'étais
pas doué puis les autres c'est pas très
sympa avec vous parce que vous étiez un
petit peu enrobé et alors on l'appelait
Jonas la baleine si tu veux à cause oui
dans les petites classes après après oui
Jonas la baleine et puis là vous en avez
marre et vous dites j'en ai marre des il
faut
ah oui j'avais un problème avec le
devoir je l'ai toujours d'ailleurs quand
ça va s'arrêter je supporte plus et là
vous partez alors vous savez pas très
bien fait de la peinture du dessin de la
comédie exacte mais avec une vraie
certitude que vous alliez y arriver
c'est vous avez jamais douté de votre
star c'était alors oui c'est ça est-ce
qu'on prévoit le futur où est bien
est-ce que cette conviction fait le
futur je sais pas parce que moi je crois
plutôt qu'on est créateur de son de sa
vie mais c'est vrai que j'avais cette
conviction là tellement j'avais oh oui
j'étais pas bien à l'école quoi ça a été
des années terribles et je me suis dit
la liberté et pour moi c'est vrai que la
liberté c'était d'avoir de ne pas avoir
de compte à rendre à quelqu'un ou un
patron etc et le truc artistique c'était
voilà voilà vous voyez avant de que la
musique m'emporte qu'elle me fasse des
des clins d'oeil et que je me laisse
séduire c'est vrai que j'ai commencé par
le dramatique j'ai commencé avec moi
quelqu'un que je connais je sais pas qui
me connaît encore ici Vigon oui Vigan et
les lemon c'est que votre copain ah moi
je connais bah oui
Vigan quand même c'est un chanteur de
chanteur de rock qui était quoi marocain
mais il est toujours il est toujours en
vivant ah ben il a toujours non
seulement mais il est toujours au Maroc
il chante toujours il a un endroit je
crois qu'il a un restaurant où il chante
tous les soirs oui oui
t'imagines ça toi et alors après vous
faites le King 7
toujours avec votre copain et puis après
vous finissez quand même par chanter
tout seul vous faites les textes avant
les musiques il y a beaucoup d'auteurs
compositeurs qui qui font l'inverse qui
commence des textes et vous c'est
l'inverse oui pour moi ça me paraît
naturel quoi c'est les mots qui vont
faire naître la musique donc je la
musique est là pour exprimer ce que
suggère le texte exactement la façon de
travailler de Julien Clerc dites le
texte porte sa rythmique et les gens
font en général l'inverse bien et bien
vous restez avec nous avec plaisir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maintenant nous allons passer
à l'anti portrait chinois de Michel
Jonasz on ne bouge pas pendant le jingle
ma fille
[Musique]
il a bougé ou pas
vous connaissez le portrait chinois le
portrait chinois c'est si tu étais une
fleur je serai à myosotisme mais non
l'anti portrait chinois c'est juste
l'inverse c'est si vous étiez une
rupture par exemple une rupture de
rythme
une injure
non mais tu m'énerves c'est quand on une
injure c'est on lance à quelqu'un ou
c'est la pire
tu m'énerves c'est ça que je dis mais tu
es fou la violence
si vous étiez une maladie
il y a des choses que je peux dire
si vous étiez une maladie ah alors une
maladie qui serait pas grave mais qui
pourrait par exemple donner de la fièvre
parce que je sais pas moi j'ai des
souvenirs d'enfants où j'avais de la
fièvre c'était dans mon lit puis je sais
pas c'était un état que qui était assez
agréable quand on était malade
ça donnait comme un vertige comme un
truc un peu coconut là et c'était pas
désagréable
si vous étiez une guerre oh ben une
guerre de mots mais alors parce que moi
j'aimais bien ça alors il est
quelquefois
ouais mais enfin quand on imite les
bruits et tout ça je savais bien faire
voilà tout ça quand on est derrière les
arbres et tout ça un vice un vice la
gourmandise si vous étiez une arme
l'humour un supplice les l'humour de
gens c'est chatouilles des châteaux des
chatouilles si vous étiez un poison
le sucre alors
un dictateur un dictateur alors là je
vais pas être original sûrement d'autres
l'ont dit mais enfin j'en vois 15 c'est
c'est Charlie Chaplin
une infirmité
j'ai été un assassin ah oui plusieurs
fois non dans des rêves mais plusieurs
fois c'est très curieux en parler un
jour
ben j'ai souvent été un assassin qui
n'était pas pris je savais qu'il savait
que quelqu'un avait tué mais il savait
pas encore que c'était moi je courais
enfin ça doit être un truc de
culpabilité
chatouille
une humiliation
tant qu'on est parti dans le très hard
si vous étiez une mort de rire voilà
Michel Jonas et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de Inna larditude abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu